pierre laurent d'abord un commentaire
brut j'en avais fait secrétaire
nationale du pc je salue gilles leclair
sur cette affaire ou plutôt cette
partielle de villeneuve sur lot parce
qu'elle est les résultats en tout cas
l'air du temps du premier tour sont
quand même assez effrayant pour la
gauche je crois que le ps doit tirer les
leçons de ce qui était en train de se
passer c'est là la quatrième fois ça
vient d'être dit que la gauche est
éliminé du deuxième tour dans une
élection et c'est pas seulement
évidemment la sphère cahuzac a joué
terriblement à villeneuve sur lot
mais c'est la sphère cahuzac plus le
roger de l'austérité des politiques qui
sont menées
donc il faut changer de cap d'urgence
c'est pour ça que nous hier à montreuil
on a réuni à l'initiative du parti
communiste du front gauche des gens
venus de toutes les familles de la
gauche
le secrétaire nationale des verts marie
noëlle lienemann emmanuel maurel du
parti socialiste parce qu'il faut mettre
il faut unir toutes les forces je suis
un ancien parti socialiste mais vous
c'est 5 les verts ces deux je vois pas
ce que c'est qu'un mail calendar et nord
la situation candidature unique la
situation d'aujourd'hui c'est que on
voit que les électeurs du front de
gauche tiennent beaux ils sont là dans
les rendez-vous dans l'est dans les
dents les partiels au soutien on
progresse très légèrement mais les
électeurs socialistes sont aujourd'hui
complètement déboussolée parce que la
politique qu'ils attendaient est bien
celle qui est menée est à l' inverse
eh bien il faut unir ses forces là il
faut que nous travaillons à rassembler
ses électeurs aujourd'hui déboussolés
mais on ne les unira que si on le fait
sur un projet fort hills et lure avec
l'austérité le mans là c'est à cela
qu'on national et marine le pen vous a
volé parce que là on est dans un
tournant historique qui se développe
vous a volé tout simplement électorat
ouvrier aux jo je crois que l'électorat
qui qui n'est pas au rendez vous hier
les les voix qui manquent aux stations
relais non mais oui c'est ça les voix
qui manque au parti socialiste
elles se sont elles ne sais des gens qui
ne se sont pas déplacés cc c'est des
gens qui ne savent plus aujourd'hui où
ils en sont parce qu'ils ont voulu une
rupture avec les politiques de sarkozy
et ils ont pour le moment pas cette
rupture
donc ils ne savent plus comment s'y
retrouver et bien c'est à nous de leur
donner des repères au front
bush mais ou pas le front gauche elle
n'y arrivera pas donc c'est pour ça que
moi je travaille à rassembler des
écologistes des socialistes qui avec
nous vont dire il ya une autre politique
possible et en rupture avec celle qui a
dessiné françois hollande hier soir sur
m6 non gilles leclair question juste
peut être une dernière question encore
sur villeneuve sur lot dimanche prochain
vous appelé à faire barrage au front
national il pas une voix pour le front
national
l'entrée d'un nouveau député du front
national ç'aurait eu un très mauvais
signal
parce que ce qui doit être construit ses
huttes une alternative à gauche aux
politiques d'austérité et donc il ne
faut pas compter sur nous pour banaliser
en quoi que ce soit l'entrée possible
député du front national à l'assemblée
nationale